[تصفيق]
تمرد انقلاب خيانه طعنه في الظهر تهور
تعددت الاوصاف قبل ان يسحب قائد فاجنر
قواته الى معسكراتهم قال انه اقدم على تلك
الخطوه تجنبا لسفك الدماء وبعد وساطه رئيس
بيلاروسيا بينه وبين الرئيس بوتين من حلف
للجيش الروسي في الجبهات الاماميه لمعركه
بخموت في اوكرانيا الى عدو يهدد بالاطاحات
بالمؤسسه العسكريه لبلاده يبكي يخلط
الاوراق والحسابات بسرعه تجعل فهم ما يجري
امرا عسيرا ومن مساء الجمعه الى السبت
حدثت تطورات كثيره وخطيره لن تنتهي بازاله
اللوحه الدعائيه لفاجنر في شوارع المدن
الروسيه موسكو تحت نظام عمليه مكافحه
الارهاب انتشار للجيش في الشوارع ونقاط
تفتيش وتعليق لحركه الملاحه في نهر
موسكوبا
للمواطنين بالبقاء في منازلهم وعدم الخروج
الا للضروره القصوى تهدد بريجين الجمعه
بالاطاحه بالقياده العسكريه والزحف من
اوكرانيا الى روسيا لم تكن مجرد كلام
فعلها ودخل مدينه روسطو تباها بانجازه
قائلا انه لم يطلق رصاصه واحده خلال
سيطرته على مركز العمليات العسكريه الروسي
الرئيسي وقاعده جويه في المدينه توعد
بالوصول الى موسكو للاطاحه بكبار القاده
العسكريين الذين يتهمهم باستهداف وقتل
مقاتله سرعان ما وجه الرئيس خطابا للامه
حذر فيه من التهديد القاتل وخطر اندلاع
حرب اهليه على يد قائد مجموعه فاجن
اولئك الذين نظموا وحضروا لتمرد عسكري
واولئك الذين حملوا السلاح ضد رفاقهم في
القتال خان روسيا وسيحاسبون على خيانت
اتوجه لاولئك الذين يتم اقحامهم في هذه
الجريمه واطلبوا منهم عدم ارتكاب خطا قاتل
وماساوي رفض بريكوجين عرض الاستسلام
الطوعي له ولمقاتليه واسهب في انتقاد
النظام الحالي
فيما يتعلق بخيانه الوطن الرئيس مخطئ نحن
وطنيون كنا ولا نزال نحارب ولا احد يعتزم
الاستسلام بطلب من الرئيس او جهاز امن
الدوله او ايا كان لاننا لا نريد ان تستمر
بلادنا بالحياه بهذه الطريقه في ظل الفساد
والكذب والبيروقراطيه
للتذكير من يتحدث عن الفساد هو رجل قضى
فتره طويله في السجن قبل ان يفتح مطعما
بسيطا للنقانق ثم سلسله مطاعم تقدم
خدماتها للرئاسه والجيش حتى اصبح يلقب
بطباخ الكريم ربما اخر ما كان يتوقعه
بوتين هو ان يسمم هذا الحليف السابق الوضع
الامني في روسيا حرب اوكرانيا المصيريه
لموسكو وخلال اليوم وصلت القوات الشيشانيه
التي ارسلها الرئيس قديروف لقمع التمرد
على حد وصفه مع مرور الوقت طالت قائمه
القرارات والاجراءات التي اتخذها الكرملين
لحمايه العاصمه وباقي مناطق البلاد من
دخول قوات فاجنر معركه بوتين بريكوجين
غموض في غموض هل هي فعلا ضربه موجعه
لموسكو في توقيت غير مناسب لحظات انتشاء
وشماته حلفاء كييف لم تدم سوى ساعات
والسؤال الاهم هل بانسحاب قوات فاجنر الى
معسكراتهم تكون هذه هي نهايه هذه الدراما
الروسيه ام هي البدايه فقط